missill balles six ans plus tard laure
buisson électorale est toujours présente
elle s'est même étoffé mais qu'en est-il
de vidéos de l'idéologie de ce parti au
discours identitaire qui refuse de se
classer à gauche comme à droite s'est
elle aussi renforcée at elle évolué ces
questions nous les adressons au
secrétaire général du pc au alexandre
line catcher ongles invités de la vie
politique pendant les 45 prochaines
minutes un entretien que vous pouvez
aussi suivre sur internet grâce au site
de la première ou sur les réseaux
sociaux et à notre chaîne youtube vous
pourrez par ailleurs jacques auditeurs
et internautes réagir si vous le
souhaitez dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission vos questions au 02 62 99 de
ville elle sombre line ken jeong bonjour
et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors les présentations tout d'abord
pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas
qui êtes-vous d'où venez vous et comment
on les voit arriver à la politique vous
est si connue pour moi la laissant avec
un michel dubun clairement avec tout
simplement connus olivier parce que
monnerat monte en l'occurrence montrant
guère des gamepads le x il écrirait alec
et puis à rester numéro 500 ch et maman
coud coûté mon écoute et papa nous sort
le chaudron donc on a sorti mes études
on retenait deux côtés chaudron parce
que mettez travaillant dans la rivière
et après nous les revenus amour mon pays
d'origine s'est refusé à moussa il
pourra effectivement les coûts le croire
et oser l'année prochaine je l'ouvrais
vous êtes vous avez étudié puis à paris
on a fait quasiment 4 5 ans à son bord
qui met un travail deux ans je suis pas
remis par la suite
et puis il était fatigué ressources
humaines et la philosophie politique à
double master et aujourd'hui vous faites
quoi j'aurais consultant les pronoms
d'accord sous deux semaines
et voilà on y travaille avec eux de
ballon loin donc des associés
avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet une
réaction peut-être sur l'actualité du
jour les transporteurs qui craignent de
mettre la clé sous la porte faute
d'activité dans le btp la commande
publique mot gestion durable de la
demande et matériaux pour la carrière
ils menacent de bloquer routes vous ce
que vous comprenez leur désarroi est ce
que vous cautionnez là
de l'équateur bloqués est-ce que nous
comprend that désarroi tout le monde que
la vocation à travailler et à la réunion
tout de même que la vocation à créer
avant d'ajouter la richesse et c'est un
exemple au derrière nous peut comprendre
que convoite aussi les productions les
mises à mal roulé par contre est normal
sodi concédera méthode alors bond -
voulu traite à nous de ceci ou de cela
continue des méthodes que nous l'employé
d'une bonne technique de combat
politique l'était pas mais on se compare
à parce que l'on transporté il fait tous
les quatre matins savoir bloquer les
routes bloquées avec une canne cédera
pour tout simplement remettre sur la
table un panachage que là on le voit
politique et le monde privé alors savoir
occasionnés au bas comme ça d'accord à
qui je parle comme ça la question
prochaine
c'est un projet encore une fois farouche
la réunion est-ce qu'il était le
meilleur est ce qu'il est et le moins
bon est ce que les conditions
faisabilité était réuni pour que l'on ne
peut nous puisse amener choix santé un
projet comme celle là qui est celui-ci
rappelle quand même les ménages
réunionnais et peut-être deux ou trois
générations à cause de la pression
fiscale et puis des jumelles
le projet le projet trop tard ou sinon
nous fait prévisionnistes mais nous
conduisent par une histoire attention
mais au fil du temps avec le problème de
la roche le problème du choix ou le
scénario des mondiaux ou des jeux
passage on veut soit rouge schnell ou
autres titres et moi comment la russie
traditionnelle une fois plus y aménage
une forme de paix sociale arrive à la
charge économique on sent bon canada et
puis fait sur la stratégie blocage
répond pas est-ce que les pour les
contre
ah mais c'est faux de demander ensuite
aux bras et ils demandent que des
troisièmes en entrant compte les autres
parce que ça les confédérés
est-ce que les inscrits dans sa chute
sont en effet des blocages de la sorte
six ans après le premier combat
électoral croire rien oser croisera ne
vous le faire une hispano mars donc sa
candidature je vais citer alors vanessa
mignolet avec mayo à 110 g qui a serré
mou à sainte marie ou même à saint
suzanne julien vanni à s'attendre et je
manie de lettres à salazie ce qu'on peut
dire déjà c'est que certains
championnats fille que nord-est pour toi
rue d'abord parce que c'est un
territoire que nous pratiquons connais
un peu plus n'a pas la prétention
indiens dalits installe à nourrir les
territoires que nous connaît un peu
moins qu'un ouvrage beaucoup les
méthodes de peut-être plus parachutage
politique ou de l'émergence est signée
ou d'un candidat il pas du tout en phase
avec l'emprise locale
c'est pas notre méthode et on pense même
que la main j'ai presque moulin réunion
il ré plus simple sans aviation
parce que j'ai l'impression que bombay
obligé le terroir est bon comité aussi
un peu plus parce que l'impressionnant
issus de ces zones a et parce que nous
pensent que quand la proposition d'un
projet d'avis sur ces territoires
on commence par fait à l'issue un
ensemble de la réunion mais on commence
à félix une pension qui présente des
enjeux qui présentent des problèmes
s'ils savent bien que les ficelles vous
apte à l'est par exemple peut régner
dans l'ouest dans le sud même par un jeu
d'alliances d'aider des gens qui qui
mais qui me paraît que l'été dollars les
alliances déjà dans le génome police
benoît reeves et c'est pas quelque chose
que et les communs chez elles et même
pas du tout qu'on allait elle n'a point
d'alliance espace eux avec des
particules a été en gestion des crues
mais les candidats on s'entend créé téoz
a fait ensuite n'a pas la prétention
effectivement de pénétrer des
territoires comme ça tout d'un coup mais
par contre nous coller que nous reste
donc aucun parti ou
107e d'avoir facilité tout demoun pour
finir ce que moi je vous liez de la
réunion et paris combat qu'il a mené ces
trois cas des années là permettent à
nous aussi de découvrir l'été les bras
du principe et territoires du comprend
des doléances de comprendre le monde y
construit aussi comme réalité et c'est
comme ça qu'on cause et c'est qu'on
sable mou et me pense que les beaucoup
un prétentieux que les formations
politiques qui tous les 6 7 et 6 ans
tous les cinq ans il reprend un épisode
devant les électeurs
alors qu'ils vont présenter souvent deux
fois et puis qui sait vous donc tipa
tipa en 2014
vous étiez enfin vous souhaitez incarner
l'autre incarner l'autre choix à saint
denis
l'autre choix donc c'était moi commence
1% des suffrages
je ne céderai pas au second tour bella
cette fois c'est fini ça nique ou ou les
sous de grands ballons bras droit
alors je pense que la façon nous faut
mieux il peut rester au lit doit
apprendre à ne pas lui le territoire
nous avons la preuve
oui moi entre ont-elles peut-être que
même à 30 ans nous n'avons qu'à sion et
le barreau produit aussi les erreurs du
passé qui veut qu'on concentre tout un
moment sur une seule personne
on sent tous un seul territoire et que
mordicus ouvert les vannes et c'est toi
le show late effet en fait on le mi6 est
un délice lascif où ça ne peut pas aller
chercher la première est donc entre un
an après au chef-lieu où soir ouvriers
sur la sixième
et puis des sceaux a en effet ouvert le
mans qui sera fait c'est ce qu'on a fait
notamment après d'évaluer il va lui
aussi belle
quid les problèmes ainsi face à tant d
écouter progressé que julia rebaptisé
fait 6 9%
donc oui parmi seize candidats je donne
la balle est donc là finalement c'est
dans la continuité
alors vous serez à sainte suzanne alors
il ya
pour le sang qui ont déclaré à lui mais
en quel conseil régional et conseiller
municipal d'opposition partant dix ans
des tic est allumée en voir aussi beaux
gosses est considéré par contre le maire
sortant maire depuis 1993 période
d'intérim par rapport à une sanction
inéligibilité enfin de poser vos
adversaires c'est plus tout me gisèle
c'est le poids lourd ça fait trembler
les communes comme si en fait c'est une
dizaine la même vision est de la même
génération on a 30 ans et ne les fassent
à am est à peu près en thème du jouet
monde a le même âge que nous faisons que
pendant quasiment 30 ans génération
voire 2d - et peut pas prendre autre
chose était même pas permis de penser
autre chose que ce que les est higuain
part à cette majorité que l'été que
l'été en place depuis 30 ans maintenant
n'a pas d'idée des gens dans nos massifs
qui ont agressé l'un des pratiques non
des choix d'aménagement à des décisions
que nous veut qu'on va par exemple des
30 ans de bilan si oui alors qu'on pose
la question est ce que cette chan a été
une ville très excédés par le squale
aucune sur sa saison
c'est la centrale a été une ville que
l'excès par l'attractivité économique
la réponse c'est nous dans la culture
française le maloya
je ne peux pas lui enlever ça oui
exemple le sévit le 115 millions
d'investis son 800e au déficit
c'est un projet de la cinor si nous
parle tout de suite la simpar métrage
mafia 2 d'aménagement de projets sur la
natation sur la pratique du sport occupe
de la culture la plus c'est pas que la
musique la littérature
là je sais quoi et moi on y est allé de
son environnement le rapport à l'ol soit
ce qu'on veut avec simulation qui votait
aussi aux dés
elle parlait les barons sont en mesure
ou prend lui la banon qui est un peu le
marché financier on a cet investissement
difficile et on à la route du son la
chose va peut-être mon programme
génération et c'est mon manager et a
nagé beaucoup d'anciens abonnés que vous
chargez d'où vient ce message est passé
vous critiquez maurice gironcel mais
lorsqu'on regarde sur son site internet
en le mot du maire s'est administré je
vais vous dire un extrait et je trouve
que le temps du discours il y avait des
centres résonance
alors il dit nous devons chaque jour
notre liberté est un défenseur sur notre
liberté léger les jeunes ont exprimé
tous ces manifestants ont ravivé notre
combativité nous sommes réapproprier
notre liberté de manifester sa liberté
d'un travail permettant d'être dignement
célébré de dire non liberté de lutter
contre les injustices dans notre pays
les gouvernements successifs qui ne
comprennent pas nos spécificités
notre situation est plutôt d'accord là
dessus c'est surtout une bonne
littérature incantatoire mieux que
d'aller c'est celle est il qu'il a écrit
lui-même nous aimer voir ce que nous
avons fait pour le quotidien un peu plus
des tissus et les rompre un monde est
jeune mais fiction pour les cocktails
sont les mais elle était plus
intéressant c'est pourquoi alors oui ça
a été présents les maires sont en tout
cas a été présent sur les barrages et
les eaux commencent par toute la classe
en fait des gros bras et les nervis la
politique l'instrumentaliser
généralement pas les moyens d'utiliser
l'argent de ses impôts de la mienne des
gens s'attendraient de savoir et de sa
flotte de sannine ou partout ailleurs à
la réunion
c'est comme ça qu'on fait la plus infime
le mouvement que ça a pu bien chef
d'ypres à son exclusion radicalise a dit
c'est-à-dire amenuisé le débat de la
problématique générale jarring depuis à
peu près 30 40 ans du parc jacques lafay
l'a fait pour la population est
aujourd'hui venir par l'ami liberté
venir parler de combativité dise pas que
ça prend moins trop hot & company
ossements de gamme là désolé conscient
du fait que l'hospice un peu plus
incarner cette chanson des 6es par le gr
laisse deux mots enfin libre
c'est la régie les jaunes pour l'instant
on va se concentrer un peu sur saint
suzanne pour le saunier qui sont allés
coûte quelques jours proposez moi c'est
usa nous disant qu'il ya un débat sur la
question
ok ok ça se voit ça se gagne 1 et qui
sont à l'écouté seront proposées pour
améliorer leur quotidien ce que vous
avez le programme il pense qu'un
programme ou wap aux paris coup de mou
en tant que tel c'est la limite à lise
deux colistiers avec lyon c'est trop ouf
un peu comme un alchimiste et magicienne
les trois incantations et puis oui bon
chemin il a trouvé cette solution c'est
ça qui vous fait que ces deux-là cédera
non je concède que la population pense
que les campagnes il sert à ça c'était
qui sert aussi à rencontre de mon écoute
azote échanger discuter vivent tout
simplement olivier kohn par le bureau
bien sûr d'être la liberté quand qu'on
pratique à territoire qu'on habite
narines ou quelle que soit la commune
habitat territoire où vivent avec le
monde nous vivent pas d hier invité avec
chauffeur avec des moyens qui permettent
tout et de débat c'est incognito pardon
et de fait des affiches temps en temps
dans le journal ou en télé ou je ne sais
quoi et où dans les institutions les
cocktails lycées y venez vivre debout ou
pratique ce que donne un conte problème
et où ça ne veut assécher les
problématiques nous encombre depuis 30
ans mais problème chez clo mais problème
d'aménagement ce gt parquet stratifié 3
prend le littoral consigne était
quasiment du ceni se sont extrêmes à
sainte-marie et opérations shass a tenté
comme ça le choix d'aménagement du
littoral qu'elle a été fait depuis
quasiment 100 ans
l'épicentre en la réunion s'est procuré
de l'île et compagnie à sainte-suzanne
ensuite lalami compte c'est houssam la
disponibilité foncière encore zicom 5
marie connaît encore un gros nid foncier
est mort de la chaufferie et puis
maintenant la ligne qui dépasse à peu
près les 500 à naucelle à peu près des
routes sèches femme que les traditions
très rural maintenant il ya un projet de
route qui pourrait passer justement ces
trois niveaux
rodéo de left là ça c'est une question
sur laquelle est voisin de l'est
alors laissez commis on va re sic grâce
à un projet de route qui passeraient
plus seulement au niveau des trois îles
vous allez dire aura lieu à 8h et une
vraiment un très haut niveau dès lors le
débat on ne sait pas par quel tracé va
être retenu
mais c'est finalement du territoire un
scénario quatre scénarios consultation
publique menée par le cabinet des chutes
qu'elle était menée par le conseil
départemental parce que en tant que tel
le but c'est de reprendre les faits
honte agricole et d'aménager à peu près
deux fois une voie
mais un système en fait je suis là son
public pas mal de choses d'abord n 1
milliard 600 millions projet un milliard
cent millions
nouvelle route du littoral d'art ou
est-ce que la d'habilité financiers et
valider ces projets structurants banc
par l'interrogation
deuxièmement le chat même jeu mode de
déplacement enfin tous vivent dans une
grande assisté à la réunion met en
parallèle des affaires comprend des
prêts beaucoup de monde globalement il
comprend où sera pas sensiblement sept
rangs des îles à ce projet de l'écurie
gym est la famille j'ai sort dans la
roue des ou de l'est 1 milliard 600
millions projet d'expropriation très
certainement pour jeu normalement la
bretagne
selon danny richmond par les gens de
durenque
on a eu notre projet de 2 c'est quoi ces
régions est là sinon projets de
transport guidé le projet région on a 90
mille véhicules qui engouffre azote au
propre s de sani tous les jours donc il
veut se construire se tissant dû
simplement s'étendait et on regarde les
deux tracés région sinon il fait des pas
de race est imminent entre gay ou pas
les champs du bac pour jeux ne soient
bientôt
soit qu'un lien de concertation ça
brille pas et c'est qu'une photographie
de l'absurdité des choix d'aménagement
que la police y traditionnels comment
vous croirez aussi vous pouvez changer
ça les stratégies c'est quoi c'est
d'avoir là sinon ça veut dire être
présenté pour pouvoir donner votre avis
la stratégie stratégie en fait l'île et
il est assez simple et voie
déconcertante
nous les fassi ouvert naîtra un état
centralisateur dans sa logique
administration de 2015 est quasiment du
miracle et iii de la décentralisation ou
lana une logique donc depuis gouvenement
valls jusqu'à zortziko est inchangé et
que lui même a changé qu'ideo les
simples le la france hexagonale dont sa
capacité à administrer
li na li en paix est le moyen est de
vitesse là plutôt morne le relais parce
que l'un à l'échelon le plus râle c'est
une baisse globale ce qui fait que les
mairies n'a de plus en plus de mal à
exercer la mission de service public ça
tous les services ranger la population
et que face à sa moue les contrats si on
veut rentrer en plus de monde
en tant qu'analyste et mais contraint de
faire face à des institutions clés de
plus en plus inopérante cette lan un
très bel exemple le bon sens inné
pouvait qu'il vive le consensus est que
six militaires à tout seul et que tu es
un troll est tout seul et connaissait du
débat tout yahoo pour trouver solution
d'écouté et que la solution des
portugais le coach menad michalis et
moyens alors on va revenir sur ces soirs
jusqu'au final sur le projet de nouvelle
métro exactement super agglomération
alors dernière ça il ya toute une
logique que vous avez déjà déployé lors
des
la crise et piotr ça comme ça lorsque le
collectif de la protection des baies est
mobilisé pour sur le domaine maritime
s'est quittés contre en 10 ans vous
étiez sur place pour dire voilà une
vidéo réappropriation des accapareurs
cccd à vous reproduisez avoue ce fil
propose une nouvelle métropole
parce que ça consiste exactement le
projet de métro proches ou veut comme
parle de liberté la liberté c'est 'qui
c'est juste la capacité qu'on pourrait
avoir a fait ce coup vu dans un cadre 50
et les talibés y est dans son bon
fonctionnement
maintenant elle pouvoir local keith
entre nous soit dit olivier serai
content
à l'heure actuelle nous parle en octobre
2019 qui ça serai content d'avoir un
territoire continu de bout en bout tu
n'auras laisse par exemple où les
capacités entreprendre les facilités
capacité d'entreprendre ses goûts et ses
montres un autre prise par lev un fonds
dispose d'un capital et de vaincre et
non pas qui ça serai content d'eux mais
d'avoir des facilités déplacement sur un
territoire continu mais c'est ce projet
qui ne portait pas la communalité qui se
serait content à la chaîne d'avoir un
logique d'aménagement du territoire
faciliter la question que nous pose
parce que nous comprend six conseils
fait peser sur les épaules d'une chaîne
épaules de 30 et n'a pas la prétention
d'autres choses la prétention de mieux
savoir où des buffets nous propose et
nous combattent pour les plans de
progrès question en équipe i tonm être
du souci qu'on y arrivera politiques
dans les pratiques pour faire la police
messone de ma famille n'a fait la
politique qui fait la politique parce
que c'est la seule méthode que l'on a
trouvée pour combattre les injustices
dans mon pays sur mon territoire
parce que vous n'avez sion en aviation
dans mon pays l'injustice où tout semble
en forme parce que moi la passe passe et
pour répondre sur la métropole bien vite
et c'est à l'occasion du gros bien c'est
d'ailleurs une première
c'est l'occasion de demander en octobre
neuf vies toute la classe politique
traditionnelle et tout autre
représentant que la fédé choix
d'aménagement depuis cinq ans 70 ans qui
s'en fait n'intéresse que les projets
concept là la nouvelle métropole où la
super glue nations ils sont pas
d'humains ciseaux la pure nous invite à
zot nous croire josé et moins à
l'agrégation à débattre de ça pour
l'intérêt général et pour la
compréhension du monde
on y reviendra pas se faire une petite
pause musicale une petite pause musicale
a causé une pause musicale
c'est le morceau pour la choisit en plus
après viendra sur les trois principes
un petit teasing et fondements
essentiels de chartes idéologique à la
conscientisation l'émancipation de
détermination mais tout de suite on
écoute ce titre de miles davis que vous
avez choisi smokes mot games in your
eyes
[Musique]
encore
m
[Musique]
non
on
m
fouet
[Musique]
bon
amamou
[Musique]
il est trompettiste il est américain il
s'appelle miles davis mans s'était donc
smoke gets in your head mais vous aimez
bien cet artiste pourquoi ce choix ce
choix olivier parce que de façon
générale il ya maloya la réunion je suis
moins de musique d'opprimer et le jazz
par excellence lille et le la
concrétisation en fête de la charité
d'existence du hockey c'est un mensonge
qui m'attend mais peut couler plus n'est
son spleen à double sens que moi
d'amener mon cela aussi bon
donc on comprend le choix du coeur de
larmes de douane où je sais que vous
pouvez dès à présent réagir un chers
auditeurs et internautes en proposant le
02 62 99 2000 et poser vos questions à
alexandre la calèche et ongles sa partie
croire et rosé qui est notre invité ce
lundi politique le standard est ouvert
alors à vous souhaiter que les gens
prennent en main leur destin s articule
autour de l'idéologie du parti illogique
ont retrouvé sur le votre site et
propose trois fondements
conscientisation émancipation
autodétermination commerce qu'on
transpose tout ça dans une famille que
de gestion go in pense que justement le
lui l'idée c'est de ne pas avoir un
raccourcis aussi rapides que la
transposition d'une idéologie à la
pratique la pratique de gestion
l'idéologie est pas fait pour être
transposé l'histoire l'a bien montré non
pas en cours de montage dans un combat
notamment dans un combat politique
elle a besoin d'une ligne de conduite
ali ne consiste qu'à une vente à
l'amiable et naïve et bah c'est un peu
mon histoire
qu'est-ce que sa conscientisation nancy
passion des mots qui gros mots portent
des gens face et je n'entends pas
souvent quelques questions m kassoum
conscientisation vous dis même d
aliénation qui savent lire en fait c'est
un gros mot
bofa sont parlés nous comprendre c'est
complexe mais mais nous fait passer des
pays où sa demande ait été dit jean il
ne croit qu et c'est une erreur d'autant
que à chaud après les mots de mon combat
avons retrouvé expliqué attention quand
denis ferrand a fait et surtout cause de
siemens le vit isolé jamais on ne peut
plus conscience que tu fais et notamment
que ce travaux des comptes redit haut et
des animations c'est tout simplement au
vu de l'histoire d'une inconnue à rythme
fm et ckoi tout le monde processus qui
tend à rendre à l'étranger en fait un de
l'environnement ademe tony doit mais
comment notre modérateur
comme en août on nous donne trois
familles comment notre temps on doit ce
qui fait de nous ses pigments ce que
nous les sens en inventant vous mettez
pas par exemple le fait qu'on envoie les
gens ici au québec par exemple ou pour
vous mon sens malade et six en dur et
602 littéralement nous réalise mon logis
lille et la mobilité
c'est pour moi qui la lient tous les
grands pays de ce monde aujourd'hui
savez vous ce n'est pas sur le modèle
nippon par exemple et mobilisera
processus aller et retour c'est à dire
que on n'a rien qu'à l'aller mais il
faut aller ensuite une fois les forêts
ni mais il fournit le pays a besoin que
son génération ses souffrances vivent en
général y investit aux autres pour la
construction la rue non demain pour la
construction d'une réunion que aussi
estimé meir d'arup semaine et ensuite
pour votre enfant et que par ce
processus à nous peut aussi fait plaisir
soyez discussions larmes il n'y a pas là
nous tous les décembre et que parce que
la fré ya envoyé bien là bras un parvis
n'importe où et des imams aux enfants
aux coliques oui une préférence
régionale quoi qu'il en soit le terminal
vous dites à venir légal vous dire que
nous les pays où de vieilles latifi
slogan la réunion et fsu en donnerez le
travail préférence régionale l'emploi
local
rémy et saha et c'est tout ce qu'on veut
nous peut pas réduire la pensée ne
laisse que deux mini pense à mon slogan
parce que le fait de reggiani à mon
slogan si le fait des débuts des ou de
mettre de côté ou les chinois y aura
toute la complexité du système dans
lequel nous les arrange bien tout
simplement préférence et jalousie un
quickie salé conquet marmaille
il sont drogués ils travaillaient la
messale est valable pour le bassin paris
ile de france n est valable le bassin
varois
les voilà pour le bassin la paca et ses
disciples ainsi qu'une trousse sur canal
que nous devons à la réunion qu'il
trouve antique ne trouve pas tout le
monde parce que la logique de dépasse
même si les choses que les complète
sortie du siège par la loi comprend très
rapide un mauvais sur le territoire nord
est à l'heure actuelle 90 un livre
peut-être à sainte suzanne et
s'attendent à ce que cette marie a déjà
connu c'est l'abandon des terres des
espaces 1 c'est marianne on protégera
des saintes maries notamment parce que
bluff et parce que la toulousaine
couffinal travail
les enseignes que scène il est là le
chef lui de la france quand on parle des
centres commerciaux vous parlez des mecs
qui permettra d'aller manger c'est vrai
travail j'en ai fait kong et le moun i
qui par exemple c'est bizarre à
d'origine saint-andré d'origine y
quitter même salaziens s'agit plus pour
le coup de saint-andré sa maman mais qui
quitte en fait le grand est ont un goût
face aux deux jambes péage poil et
nourrit les concessions automobiles et
nourrisent si je manque pour pouvoir
je ne voterai plus étranglée v j'ai vu
qu'il y avait ça cholet et l'a fait de
bout séjour penser que l'exemple en fait
sombre comme une banlieue sont venus
dans l'art est ce un problème qui dit
attendons tous les ans tous les pays sûr
il existe à isis beaucoup et on fait
tout lui parce que tout simplement les
dirigeants plan les îles de sagnet
l'heure actuelle et en se montrant
beaucoup et bien focalise toute
stratégie développement sur le
centre-ville aujourd'hui sa population
des congrès sont absentes
visa sans que la construit pas sur
l'économie tunisienne
mais tout le système de projection la
réunion et avait pour l'économie
réunionnaise il asphyxie selon amina et
le nom aménagement des parkings en
centre ville
le fait de faire des travaux
clientélisme mythe six mois avant les
élections
le fait de confier à verbaliser les gens
qui est donc d'opposer les mettre en
place les conditions pour créer du
travail à sainte-suzanne par exemple si
on a quinze tradégie d'expansion du
modèle obsolète et des usa ni vers les
deux parents pauvres de la science
c'était son mari cette finale mais
forcément par des goulets d'étranglement
discute on croit découvrir son enseigne
après longtemps qu'ils n'allaient
connectés mais une baisse de 70% du
chiffre d'affaires et le fait que les
dieux monsieur le maire autre que là en
fait fait place à nickel traitement les
graphies populaire à l'heure actuelle
noah compal ont fait de la logique du
logement avec cette stratégie de
concentration
le fait de vider cette un opérateur
construction substantifique moëlle
financier en 1 tm poulets s'est en fait
les opérateurs étatique reprendre la
main là dessus nous ça fait tout de même
jour par le centre ne peut parler
exactement de céder ou territoriale
opération avec l'annoncé chez la mère et
nous parle bien sûr au dessus de la ceni
que les devenu cdc à pitre une finale
notamment de l'état entend elle
accueillera ce soir
les faits parlent aux gens qu'on
retrouve aussi dans le cas où ça fait
cool de match où donc est depuis 2016
doivent être chassenay d'ahlam 80% du
logement de choses dont les anciens à se
dessiner l acide du main avec les
orientations financières et doit
financer à peu près de trois ans que
tetra des gens finira le fait que le
logement intermédiaire il sait être le
nouveau modèle de construction et
d'aménagement signale toujours des
profits soit pour en beauce trois fois
le coût d'investissement cool a fait
quasiment à zéro à la glose opération
n'est pas et compagnie lebon logements
construits ou bien le camp d'en face
la conscientisation mais émancipation l
autodétermination l'a peut-être il ya
des gens qui font moins vous suisse
parce qu'on sait que la réunion spectre
de houla l'autonomie l'indépendance ça
résonne un peu sonné dans le même champ
lexical groupe lacroix et coup lâche
olivier
hélas il ya quelque chose à clarifier la
chance d'être une génération et il salue
peut-être une bonne détracteurs qu'il a
toujours vous écoute quoi labs à oui
biensur en ce lundi matin touche cela de
très tendue radicaux votre identité je
ne sais quoi c'est pour identité siens
ces insultes le traitement que ceux ci
ont fait il est une insulte mais il
pense qu'une époque à la réunion et nous
ils trouvent toujours très cocasse c'est
ce folklore la cua y arrive pour parler
de wells 6 et maria défaite du mans à
vannes le fait de manger en famille
c'est bien elle est très ancien le
ridant m en fait dans le traitement
politique de l'identité
c'est la question qui présente
maintenant que la classe politique
traditionnelle dans son ensemble de
gauche comme de droite
zana des positions communes est une
jeune formation politique qui fait que
si l'on l'a rappelé olivier henin après
qu'on soit rien d'autre si ce n'est
peut-être de le prince des vrais
problèmes chatham et d'avarice offrant
l'aide de moules si ça a un peu fait
peur
il répète encore une fois mais grand
quai mais évitera à peut-être changé a
dit brad l autodétermination
émancipation s'émancipe de quoi
autodétermination on a plutôt complet
c'est par rapport à albi donc aussi de
quoi par exemple
oui mon sipa ou du cade qui peut
paraître trop pesant après travail et
que l'on est en train de galérer
parce que peut être ni aux minima
sociaux ribbeck inclus et que limite
poulies le mois et devient un chemin de
croix partielle du tice apprécié du 10
olivier
mais l'émancipation c'est un gros mot
pose simplement que mon centre d'amp
collabos difficulté fait embaucher ou
bien même peut-être des fois pour les
matins car les oies famille parce qu'on
apprend loto où il est bien obligé
qu'on a besoin de construire à brûler
vos enfants demain vous pour aller se
réunissent quelque chose de même aux
enfants
il faut bien que les conditions
financières voire les conditions
foncière qui permettent aux 2,7 une
émancipation et même de façon un peu
plus globale à la réunion l'émancipation
c'est ce qu'ils permettent à nous d'être
en phase avec nous sommes toujours
alexandre line catcher général du parti
croire et osez vous pouvez poser vos
questions à notre invité au 02 99 2000
on a compris son élection d'idéologie
votre défi peut-être un ce sera il ya
deux défis de citoyenneté de réussite
dans les élections c'est de renouer la
confiance dans la classe politique
et deuxièmement de combattre la montée
du front national
on la foulée 1-1 lyon devant la france
insoumise
comment est ce que vous allez faire on
sent qu'il ya quand même des amours la
classe politique est monté de radio
quelque chose holliger quelles
formations politiques ou quel
spécialiste ou espère la politique à la
réunion je les ont noué dans les médias
n'a eu le courage nous traiter donne une
vraie analyse post jeunes les postes
mouvement du 17 novembre prenait
traduction dans les yeux qu'il a été aux
moines mais c'est 31% leur international
à la réunion c'est les échéances à venir
qui s'impose réellement une analyse au
dessus comme ici une vraie analyse à ça
- les e montée des extrêmes le vote
contestataire les français les
réunionnais ne se reconnaissent plus en
termes d'identification dans une classe
politique les dirigeants un désaveu un
désamour c'est le constat c'est un
scandale et à lison c'est à dire en
quelques mots
l'analyse madiot jouent-ils principes
émis pense que l'appréhension dôme de
muda réunion l'a toujours été
profondément rebelles d'avoir une
rebelle pas révolutionnaire elle voulait
prendre vos belles
mais il fait penser à une phrase al
islah qui dit comme ça et moi les
rebelles parce que me laisse cuire et
c'est typiquement fait une situation
nous les rebelles hutus cela fait de
nous ce que nous et quand on a plus
l'habitude de voir en fait des gens qui
représentera au combat qu il combat qui
sont venus combattre convives venus
combattre une idée est agréable de vimy
tout avec à vivre ensemble
je ne savais pas ce que c'est un combat
et n'a pas besoin leur annulation qu'on
appuie sa écoulée fera son arrivée
quant aux dons politiques que est
complètement déconnecté des réalités que
vivent que ce soit mais de frigidaires
comment ça n'est pas ça aux cons ça
d'aller chercher la confiance à
transmettre à lille demain comment ça
règle pas la facture en bonnes âmes donc
on va à jamais nos gouvernants cocorico
on passe à messein front national auquel
il sa règle ses comptes entre
merveilleux pourquoi la réunion olivier
le vote qu'il fait sur leur assemblée
nationale il est fait en fait une figure
où sur le territoire hexagonal qu'il est
exactement mais n'a pas fait de cadeau
c'est la partie des treize structures et
n'a pas de représentant avec la même
station le même charisme pour madame le
pen à la réunion bien sûr donc quel est
l'intérêt entre guillemets demain
d'aller voter pourrait penser que la
presse directement des sciences dans un
virus si ce n'est peut-être affranchis
marotte lomé et à installer par la suite
rationnel dans la tête et dans les
isoloirs
généralement quand on parle de vol
clientéliste c'est parce que ça oui
employé communal ou famille travail de
la commune le clan des choses que vous
combattez vigueur oui parce que glee les
causes entre guillemets et contrats
aidés aussi et le contrat il est rentré
pour vous c'est en tout cas lille et
lille en france on lit la france en ce
sens qu'est ce qui en fait la
pérennisation et développement si vous
êtes amenés aux responsabilités à
certains contrats
il finit juste en fait chez la
romancière parce que très peu le 17
novembre sa de moon l'a 10 39 d'autres
albums de mon najih et la pointe du
doigt les problèmes que nous tous tu
nous connais la réunion et du gossip qui
ça les responsables centraux demain la
première traduction poste nous avons vis
à douvrin c'est effectivement ces
bracelets que les sur représentés à 31%
à 15 ou 20 % des rires
il vous dira que entrants tels l'énergie
combres l'énergie qu'on marque de huy
pente
il a été traduit tout de suite après
dans quelque chose que j'apprécie dans
sa vie de tous les jours la vie sociale
mais qui peut permettre à joe dumars
c'est quand même jamais quand même de
porter ce rassemblement national au
parlement européen c'est l'incident
parce que maintenant alors oui lyon
c'est à dire que tout ce qui va changer
par exemple
tout ça c'est ça n'appartient donc
quelque part ça a un impact bien que les
gens ne le savent pas c'est que les gens
ne le comprennent pas ça je ne me
comprends
est ce que devenaient les télésites
assad mais quoi qu'il en soit ça va ça
va sans incidence puisque l'europe
décide et nous a une incidence musyoka
entrants tels si le rassemblement
national où la france est soumise
navré du vrai parce qu'ils ne parlent
qu'en local mm robert en mai l'accord
mais quoi qu'on pense que mini 6 de
mieux en fait il était conscient que
effectivement leurs instances nationales
et propre est vrai projet et parle d'un
contrat d'un an
en place il fait très bon temps mais le
monde est conscient d'une chose c'est
que entrants tels le parti duras - qui
puisait à la réunion légré brassy
d'affichage les capacités d'affichage
pour récupérer des points mais profond
de la tête du monde pour cristalliser
mécontentement c'est que si on a
toujours parlé mais finale juillet s'il
a toujours parlé je vote alimenter mais
là plus rien manger d'offrir n'a plus
rien à part je ne lui dirais de la
blouse ont fait comprendre ça en fait
and bones élite mais dirigeants mais
vrai la joue sur le thème c'est le col
on comprend bien pourquoi son créole que
c'est vraiment une marque de fabrique ou
l'amener qu'on a vraiment un combat là
dessus
comment ça il fait partie maintenant
c'est du parti pourquoi ou avis tout
temps la sucer parce que pour ce que les
vaches folles mais c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'on met en avant par
manon houde ça ou une très bonne si la
formule de participer à sa fille et puis
me fais pas ci me pons de nous
rhétorique et la cour sa rhétorique la
réunion ça c'est le jeune mûri le crâne
c'est une ambition politique derrière
c'est une démonstration dans une société
où tout est complètement lisse et
consensuelle
le simple fait et ce qu'on veut
fédératrice à sa peine ne parlait pas
douter dans un meeting
outre ces débats ou même se leurrer nous
administratives ou je ne sais quoi ou
même professionnellement les déjà une
appli iphone alors me comprends pourquoi
un beau coup de mou qui vous est très
tendue radical ceci de cela parce que
simplement de cause créole on va
terminer comment vous allez parti parti
comment ça va se passer ce que moi là où
ça parce qu'ils consomment onzième
génération après on a des choses que
nous n'avons pas oublié et parce que
comme ideo ou yen ou profondément
et me crois que au delà c'est ça notre
adn cours il restera rien de la salette
et 600 fondre à mugello c'est commencer
la campagne où les déjà devoir de moulis
et oui c'est se monte déjà noué coup de
mou qui regarde et vous qui vous
prévient de chinois des grands ballets
arrive c'est au hockey c'est très
souvent présent terminée vous pouvez la
retrouver en podcast sur notre site
internet où notre page de youtube merci
avec sandrine calèche et ongles jusqu'à
du parti croire ou d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci à la pour la merci à
vous auditeurs de nous suivre votre
fidélité
merci à pascal langlois la technique
mathias au standard je vous laisse en
compagnie de sonia et aujourd'hui nous
mettons à l'honneur la carrière de
michel berger douce nostalgie quand tu
nous tiens la compagnie du pianiste on
adore tous ces bons soumettrait pas
journée vous les coupes de la première
[Musique]